hello everybody we're currently counting
down from 75 I don't know why it's gonna
be bad
hey here we go oh good
Oh No
ah okay that's all I gotta do oh I just
got to survive until it says it's okay
ha how gonna do that can I go in the
basement would that be easier
well badly that'd be these I'm not gonna
do that right away sorry everybody still
got a little hangover cough
all right let's do this little girl huh
you know mess with me
you're gonna mess with the last of the
greatest how'd you seek
night light in the dark like this and I
like to play D James well I do never
depreciate it Oh God
I'm going today oh no why what happened
what was I supposed to do
am i what am i I'm not a hundred percent
on board with anything again oh hi
what oh why did I die the first time man
no well that doesn't make anything Gong
damn sense I died the first time
why why why we're dead happen man I
gotta find her through the whole house
what for an hour that's a lot of finding
I don't know if I'm up to the task
I'll Giersch daring it oh hey what's
going I could could I just wait the
clock down I mean I see you there but I
mean if I don't go up to you right away
then that's gonna be okay
did I like just walk right into her and
I wasn't with poker all right I found
you I didn't even know how suppose find
you
man what a douche hi okay got her okay
so this seems simple enough simple a
nerf so just don't step on her if only
I'd known what made me leave so much
easier okay so I guess I do have to
hurry if I don't find her right away
then there's gonna be a bit of a problem
because it's gonna be LaHaye I guess I
guess I could once I need to find her a
certain number of times
I didn't read up that far okay nice
hairstyle by the way before a loser
nice rotten dress for someone that
doesn't know fashion huh where'd you get
it the toilet store oh man me ah
oh nice bare feet oh I guess you just
don't have shoes
oh nice choice of hiding place Oh
where'd you get it
the being bad at hiding store nice I got
her Oh
roasted her up ah Oh what a loser oh man
Oh where's your parents huh did you kill
them oh man oh man oh man your only
friend is a clown a mannequin and a doll
okay that's okay
you finally move somewhere original good
for her good for here is it rather
bizarre game hide and seek don't know
why it seems like this little girl just
wants to play besides her murderous
compatriots but you know overall pretty
good seems to be inline with the mind of
a little girl I got nothing against it
she seems to be a-okay in my book what a
wonderful little girl
except for the murder I'm killing your
berries Lee my parents didn't lock her
in the basement when she died okay not
doing a very good job at hiding I gotta
admit you know of all the hiders and
seekers that I've seen in my world they
don't usually stand in the middle of the
room just facing away and covering their
face with their hands you know you could
do a little more like hide in a box me
in the closet with closed No okay fine
ready mmm
Cheers how did I die the first thing
oh sure sure sure but I'm sure sure how
about is it sure I dare you feel I must
have just walked right into her how do
you know any better now that nights
gonna end and I'm gonna be able to move
on any minute now
any minute now any minton to know any
man in the know
any minute now I'll play a game one more
time that's it hmm
oh hey come on you're not even trying
there that would be a place where I'll
just run Enya
if I'd come through the other way in the
door you might have just killed me
straight up and that wouldn't have been
cool look you need to play by the rules
of hide-and-seek one you're hiding bad -
your dress is stupid 3 your hairstyles
old you're not Daenerys storm dragon
rage Stormborn and three for three
you're stupid sounds longer I need to do
this oh I called it this is I was
complaining delivered has been done to
me
okay so what do I got to do next one how
the stakes gonna be raised let me at
least find out what the deal is before I
move on to the next episode let my
smoothes me you're on of - hmm that's a
bag of asses if I ever I saw one
okay so I'll save that for the next
episode
but that's all I got for this one thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always
in the next video an experimental virus
multiple versions same guy what